imagine going to a coffee shop connected
to the Wi-Fi that just says free coffee
shop Wi-Fi looks pretty normal you're
doing a normal thing but sometimes that
normal looking Wi-Fi is actually hosted
by a random person not the coffee shop
trying to imitate that Wi-Fi access and
steal your data once you log into your
email or Worse even your bank account
your data could be compromised now and
look there's a lot of Bad actors out
there on the internet but fortunately
for you today's video is sponsored by
nordvpn which is helping to give
internet users a proper 21st century
online experience now you may have heard
me talk about what nordvpn can do for
you previously Crypt your internet data
move your activity to another location
with just a single click either for a
superior security or just for better
streaming options on Netflix Etc and all
that is still true nordvpn has more than
5 500 servers in 59 countries but vpns
give you access to so much more than
just new TV shows with Nord you can
really do it all and that includes
utilizing their threat protection
upgrade which blocks ads eradicates web
trackers checks for malware and much
look right now you guys can get a unique
deal you get a two-year plan a huge
discount plus four additional months
totally for free and look if you try
nordvn and change your mind if you don't
like it which I can't see why you
wouldn't but you'll get a 30 day money
back guarantee and all you got to do is
go to nordvpn.com bio again that's
nordvpn.com bio two-year deal huge
discount four months for free there's a
link below and now today's video
in 1942 the second world war was going
badly for Great Britain their army had
been thoroughly beaten by the Germans in
France in the Mediterranean and in North
Africa and the island was still being
subjected to regular bombardments by the
luftwaffe British generals looked
completely inept and foolish compared to
their German counterparts and what the
public and Winston Churchill desperately
needed was someone who could turn that
situation around they founded in the
person of General Berner Montgomery one
of the most controversial figures on the
Allied side of World War II undoubtedly
he was a brilliant Battlefield Commander
staging some of the European theater's
most impressive victories but it was
also vain egotistical and Bully beloved
by his soldiers but utterly detested by
his colleagues and superiors
Bernard law Montgomery was born on
November the 17th 1887 in South London
his father Henry and Anglican clergyman
was named Bishop of Tasmania two years
after Burnham was born and the family
would spend most of his childhood living
on the small island off the coast of
Mainland Australia Henry would spend
months at a time in the rural
Hinterlands of Tasmania acting as a
missionary leaving his wife bored in
charge of Bernard and his eight siblings
Ward's preferred form of discipline was
ruthlessly beating her children for the
slightest of infractions and young
Bernard spent as much time as possible
out of the house so much ill feeling
built up towards his mother the NATO
life he would refuse to have of anything
to do with her Montgomery's troubled
childhood made him into something of a
bully with a tendency towards cruelty at
times he was very nearly expelled from
the raw Military College at Sandhurst
after a hazing incident ended with a
fellow Cadet in the hospital severely
burned after Montgomery had set his
shirt on fire he survived the near Miss
however and was commissioned as a
British army officer in 1908. Monty as
his military colleagues called him
served with distinction in the first
world war he received a very serious
wound in October 1914 that always
claimed his life but he survived and
ended the war as a major he was still a
major 10 years later though the
superiors were continually annoyed by
his tendency to stick his nose in other
people's business and his overall
arrogance in United 70 married Betty
Carver a war Widow with two sons to
which they added a third son David in
1928. the marriage probably saved
Montgomery's army career as Betty
rounded out some of the more prickly
sides of Monty's personality ten years
after they were married Montgomery was a
brigadier on the fast track to his
General Stars when tragedy struck while
a holiday an insect bite Betty received
became infected and she died of sepsis
Montgomery was heartbroken he threw
himself back into his work and though
soon plenty of that to be had
foreign
[Music]
1939 Hitler invaded Poland touching off
World War II Major General Montgomery
nearly appointed commander of the third
infantry division was dispatched to
France as part of the British
expeditionary Force commanded by Lord
gaud in battle of France in May 1940 the
German fairmarked took the Allies by
surprise with a blitzkrieg offensive
through the Arden Forest successfully
outflanking the bef and three entire
French armies cutting them off from the
rest of the country as the rest of the
French army collapsed the BF was
evacuated from the port of Dunkirk along
with thousands of French troops
Montgomery performed admirally under try
circumstances but he earned himself no
friends when he returned to London and
immediately started telling everyone
from Winston Churchill on down how badly
he felt the war in France had been
fought and how he believed it should be
done correctly the fact that these plans
usually involved himself in them did not
go unnoticed by his superiors and this
would be a consistent theme for the
remainder of Monty's War he also
personally irritated Churchill
Montgomery was Fitness conscious he did
didn't smoke drink or eat meat and he
exercised vigorously this moderate
lifestyle which earned in the nickname
the Spartan General was held up by
Montgomery as an ideal standard of
living no doubt part of his overall
penchant for vanity and self-promotion
for the Potbelly church or famous for
his ability for cigars and whiskey
Montgomery came across as a preachy
know-it-all as a result of his own
popularity he was passed over the combat
commands restricted to posts in Southern
England two years passed and still
Montgomery was left chafing at home
helpless to do anything but watch his
defeat after defeat was inflicted upon
the Allies France had surrendered in
1940 the British were defeated by the
Germans in Greece and on Creed the
Japanese had entered the war in 1941
dragging the United States with them and
they had seized the British colonies of
Hong Kong Singapore and Burma while
taking the Philippines from the United
States on the Eastern Front the Germans
had penetrated deep into the Soviet
Union almost to the doorstep of
starland's Dakar and Moscow and in North
Africa the British had been forced out
of Tunisia and had 33 000 soldiers taken
prisoner when the city of De Brooke fell
in June 1942 the British eighth Army had
been chased across Libya to Egypt by the
German Africa Corps commanded by desert
fox Phil martial Owen Rommel one of
Germany's best generals Rommel was now
within Striking Distance of seizing the
Suez Canal which would [ __ ] all the Ally
Supply Pipeline and beyond that were the
oil fields of the Middle East
desperately needed by the fuel hungry
German panzers the eighth Army had to
stop Rommel at all costs but Churchill
felt that the generals currently
employed down there weren't the ones for
the job Monty was about to get his
chance
[Music]
General Claude orkenlack who was serving
as both commander of the eighth Army and
as commander-in-chief of all forces in
the middle least Churchill flew to
Africa and fired him from both roles
replacing him as commander-in-chief with
General Harold Alexander and his eighth
Army Commander with General William Gott
the next day however God was killed when
his plane was shot down leaving church a
little loss for who to appoint next
since 1941 the chief of the Imperial
general staff the head of the British
army had been General Alan Brooke
Montgomery's core commander in France
Brooke recommended Montgomery as eighth
Army Commander arguing that while he was
personally difficult he was at heart a
professional Soldier and an excellent
leader of troops Churchill relented and
on August 8 1942 Monty was given the
appointment that would make him a
household name worldwide five days later
Monty took command of a demoralized and
disorganized Army that was accustomed to
retreat he immediately set about
refitting it making a point to visit
every unit under his new command so that
the soldiers could see him his Supreme
self-confidence which had so annoyed his
colleagues over the years was exactly
what the troops needed to see the
message was clear to everyone the losing
it stopped now two weeks after taking
Bond Rommel tested Monty for the first
time in a five-day engagement known as
the Battle of alam al-halfa the Germans
bagged by their Italian allies attempted
to flank the British army trying to draw
them out of their prepared defensive
positions where they could be destroyed
instead they ran into a trap Montgomery
placed the bulk of its tanks on top of a
ridge 20 miles behind the lines they sat
up their immobile acting as anti-tank
guns to blast apart the pandas combined
with a coordinated Air Attack From the
desert air force the British armor saw
off the attack and Rommel ordered a
retreat over the next month Montgomery
steadily built up his forces and then on
October 23rd he Unleashed them in the
climactic Battle of El Alamein for 10
days the eighth Army made up of units
from India Australia New Zealand South
Africa Greece and France in addition to
British troops sought to break through
the German and Italian lines a brutal
War of Attrition the Montgomery knew he
would win finally with supplies
especially gasoline running dangerously
low Rommel was forced to retreat with
his mobile units leaving most of his
infantry to be captured now as rommel's
turn to go on the run with Montgomery
chasing after him that chase would end
in Tunisia in May 1943 when the eighth
Army now joined up with Allied units who
had invaded Morocco in Operation Torch
forced what was left of the Africa
quarter surrender Rommel Hitler's
favorite General was evacuated
beforehand El alamin was the first major
Allied victory in the European theater
of the war and overnight Monty was
everybody's favorite General he was
given a Knighthood and promoted and the
British press were quick to eat Laurels
upon him proclaiming him the best
British general since the Duke of
Wellington the most important impression
he was to make though was not with the
British public but with his American
Allies and it wasn't a good one
foreign
operation was the invasion of the
Italian island of Sicily operation Husky
for the first time Montgomery in the
eighth Army would be working in concert
with the Americans including his new
commanding officer General Dwight D
Eisenhower Eisenhower had a difficult
job as the commander of all allied
forces in the European theater trying to
balance the expectations of his bosses
in Washington with those are the other
members of the western Allied Coalition
and successfully fight the war at the
same time Monty didn't make things easy
for him when it came to operation husky
however Montgomery insisted that the
plans for the operation were all wrong
and threatened to resign if the plan he
put forward wasn't followed to the
letter just as he'd expected Monty got
his way but he had encountered on the
commander of the U.S 7th Army General
George Patton being just as much of a
premid honor as he was Patton nicknamed
all blood and guts was similar in many
ways to Montgomery both had difficult
relationships with their superiors while
being beloved by their subordinates they
craved glory on the battlefield and the
publicity it brought and they were
skilled Generals in Mobile armored
Warfare in hindsight they were probably
too alike to be expected to work
together without controversy the
invasion of Sicily was ultimately
successful but because the two Army
commanders spent more time trying to
one-up each other than working together
over a hundred thousand axis troops that
might have been cut off and captured
managed to escape to the Italian
Mainland with patterns sidelined by
press reports that he slapped and
berated Two Soldiers suffering from
battle fatigue which is today known as
PTSD Montgomery's next job as eighth
Army Commander was the invasion of the
Italian Peninsula once again the
campaign was marked by poor Allied
coordination in the face of determined
German resistance the Italians having
switched sides and surrendered to the
Allies by this point Montgomery bitterly
complained in his diary and to his
superiors in London about the disjointed
effort but the uncomfortable truth was
that the Battle of Italy was a sideshow
and everyone knew it the real Hammer
blow would come in France where the
Allies were preparing The cross-channel
Invasion known as operation Overlord
the plan was to land American British
and Canadian troops on the beaches of
Normandy punching through the
fortifications of Hitler's Fortress
Europe liberating Paris from the Nazis
grip and pushing on to Germany itself
once again their Supreme Commander
Eisenhower would oversee the operation
Allied cohesion dictated that a British
general serve as his commander in the
field during the initial stages of the
invasion
but which one Eisenhower wanted General
Alexander because the other choice
Montgomery he felt was too difficult to
work with General Brooke however
successfully convinced Churchill that
Monty was a better tactical General than
Alexander so Montgomery got the job and
was brought home to London leaving the
eighth Army behind in Italy after 18
months commanding It Montgomery worked
his magic on the assault troops making
sure to visit all of his units as he did
with the eighth Army raising morale
Monty was a proven winner and that's
what the nervous armies needed right now
after all the last successful
cross-channel Invasion had been done by
William the Conqueror 900 years before
despite many hardships on June 6 1944
the largest ambibious Landing in the
history of the world took place the
Allies successfully landed five
divisions in France 150
000 men Montgomery in addition to being
overall commander was also commander of
the 21st Army Group which consisted of
the second British army and eventually
the first Canadian Army American General
Omar Bradley meanwhile commanded the
12th Army group initially consisting of
the first Army and later joined by the
third and the ninth the Allies found it
tough going the British and Canadians
were pinned down by increasing numbers
of German troops which prevented them
from capturing the Strategic city of
Kane the Americans meanwhile found it
difficult to successfully Traverse the
countryside which was broken up into a
series of irregularly shaped and Tall
hedgerows known as barcage which the
Germans used to their advantage to make
life difficult for the Invaders
eventually Montgomery was forced to use
his British and Canadian troops like a
shield holding the Germans in place
while the Americans swung around like a
door hinge finally after two months of
battle the U.S third Army commanded by
Patton broke out and wheeled around to
the south of the Germans trapping them
in between the Americans and the British
ten thousand Germans died and 50 000
were captured in the filet pocket German
resistance crumbled at this point and
the Allies raced for Paris and the
German border a great Victory had been
won but controversy reigned over what to
do next the British believed a single
thrust by the entire group of four
armies should be made through Belgium
and Holland and then attacked the German
industrial Heartland the Aurora Valley
Eisenhower however favored a broad front
strategy which included separating the
American and British armies having the
British attacked to the North and the
Americans to the South Monty who was
also chafed Eisenhower and the latter
decided to take command of the armies
currently in the field on September the
1st leaving Montgomery only in command
of the 21st Army group once again
Montgomery can play to London claiming
Eisenhower didn't know what was going on
and questioning his Fitness to command
he also made himself look petulant when
he refused Eisenhower's invitation to
participate in the celebration
surrounding the liberation of Paris but
it was Montgomery who wasn't able to
appreciate the whole picture not
Eisenhower by this point 75 of the
troops in Europe were American with more
coming over every week the American
public would not accept a British
commander in charge of a large number of
American troops for the remainder of the
war Bradley also wanted nothing more to
do with Montgomery who he regarded as
over-cautious pompous and entirely to
preoccupied with getting its picture in
the newspaper but to the British he was
still their man hoping to placate him
somewhat Churchill promoted Monty to the
rank of field Marshal
[Music]
by September 1944 the Allied Advance was
running out of steam they were running
into the heavily fortified secret line
on the German border and their supplies
were still coming ashore in Normandy
hundreds of miles to the rear what they
needed was a deep water port on the
channel Coast like Antwerp which had
been liberated on the fourth but the
port couldn't be used because the
Germans still held the entrance to the
Shelt Estuary which controlled access to
the port many top Allied commanders
believe that Montgomery should focus on
clearing the shout above everything else
but Monty still focused on his own plan
for invading the Rural Valley in Germany
proclaimed that he had a better idea
operator Market Garden Market Garden
would see three divisions of
paratroopers dropped near the Dutch
cities of Eindhoven nikum again and
arnim to seize the river Crossings in
each one then British armored units
would race up the road to secure these
bridges that last of which in ahem was
across the Rhine River the roadway in
Germany itself if successful the Allies
could have flanked the secret line and
possibly win the war in Europe before
the end of the year the fact that the
plan was over ambitious only revealed
itself after the battle was over the
British tanks never made it on him and
the paratroopers there took Dreadful
casualties though dressed up as a
victory for propaganda purposes Market
Garden was in reality a strategic
failure that did nothing to hasten the
end of the war and cost the Allies 15
000 casualties Montgomery Chatham for
one of the first times in his life would
admit later that market Goddard was a
mistake though he took great pains to
qualify by proclaiming that if he'd been
properly supported with supplies from
headquarters that it could have been
successful belatedly Montgomery turned
his attention to Antwerp by which time
the shot had been reinforced by the bear
marked the Canadian Army would suffer
another 12 000 casualties before they
were able to open the port on November
28th in December it was the turn of the
Americans to be humiliated Hitler
failing to grasp the reality that the
war was lost gathered all of his
remaining strength through a bold strike
against the Western allies learning of
the friction between Montgomery and
Bradley he hoped to divide the two Army
groups recapture Antwerp and cut the
Allies off from their supplies if he
could force the Americans and the
British to sign A Separate Peace deal
with Germany he could then turn all of
his forces on the Soviets bearing down
on him from the east on December 16th
the Germans took the American first Army
by complete surprise suddenly attacking
from the ardenne just as they had done
to the French in 1940. four hundred
thousand men and 1 400 tanks smashed
into the American positions which
quickly gave way under the onslaught
General Bradley had been focused on the
offensives he was planning was as
flabbergasted a radio communication was
cut off so he wasn't sure what was going
on the Germans pushed West creating a
Salient or bulge in the Allied lines
newspapers dubbed the engagement the
Battle of the Bulge with things reaching
a crisis Point Eisenhower directed that
the first and Ninth American armies
which were now pinned north of the Bulge
should be temporarily transferred to
Montgomery's command Monty couldn't seem
to help but gloat at the predicament of
the Americans portraying himself as the
man who rode in and saved the day to
both his British superiors and to the
Press for a man that hardly ever
admitted to making a mistake he sure was
quick to point out perceived failures
that he saw in others for Eisenhower
this was the last straw well yes Bradley
had made a mistake there was no need to
humiliate the man that many viewed as
one of the US Army's most professional
soldiers he planned to send a message to
both Washington and London proclaiming
that either montigos or he would
realizing that he had gone too far that
Churchill would not protect him if the
cost was the risk of the entire Alliance
falling apart Montgomery was quick to
apologize Eisenhower was persuaded to
keep him in command meanwhile the German
offensive in Belgium was never destined
to do more than give the Allies a bloody
nose they didn't have enough left of
anything food fuel ammunition men to
sustain the offensive for more than two
weeks and once the Dismal winter weather
cleared and the Allies could start to
utilize their overwhelming air
superiority to attack the Germans the
offensive stalled out Fierce American
Defenders had held the line and it would
be General pattern that would get the
glory from this fight with his famous
counter-attack with the third Army
Montgomery meanwhile seemed to be
received nothing but Scorn
the Bulge had consumed the best of
Germany's remaining military strength in
the west and once it failed the entire
battle line began to collapse in March
1945 the Allies crossed the Rhine and
began racing across Germany by the start
of April the war was all but one
Montgomery believed it was possible for
him to make a dash with his army group
to Berlin to get there before the
Russians but Bradley took the wind out
of his sails when he insisted to
Eisenhower that his ninth Army which had
been under Monty's command since the
Bulge be returned to him using only his
British and Canadian troops Auntie
wouldn't be able to get to Berlin and
then he was specifically ordered not to
by Eisenhower who decided that the Elbow
River o was to be the boundary between
Western and Soviet zones Eisenhower knew
that the altar conference had already
determined that Germany and Berlin were
to be split up into occupation zones
post-war and since Berlin was within the
Soviet area why should he expend
American lives trying to capture it of
course Eisner I probably didn't realize
what Churchill was starting to do by
this point that Stalin every bit the
brutal dictator that Hitler was had no
intention of relinquishing control of
the territories that he conquered from
the Germans promises told elections
proved Hollows the Soviets set up a
series of communist satellite States in
Eastern Europe setting the stage for the
Cold War but at the time it seemed most
important to win the war against the
Nazis and the Japanese as they say
hindsight's 2020. Monty's war ended on
May the 4th when he accepted the
surrender of all German forces in
Northwest Germany Denmark and the
Netherlands he remained in Germany as
part of the army of occupation until
1946 when he was promoted to chief of
the Imperial general staff to replace
Phil Marshall Brook the post he held
until 1948. he served as Deputy
commander of NATO from its creation
until its retirement in 1958. after
leaving military life he published his
Memoirs which were deeply critical of
Eisenhower and others including Gort
archenlach pattern and Bradley the book
produced immediate blowback especially
from the United States and has indented
controversy ever since he served in the
House of Lords as Montgomery of Alamein
until he died in 1976 aged 88. these
days your opinion of Berner Montgomery
is probably based on where you're from
to the British is a hero the savior of
Britain the victor of Alamein Sicily and
Normandy to many Americans however
Montgomery is seen as a popish British
Dandy the foil of their own heroic
generals especially Eisenhower and
patton the truth is probably somewhere
in the middle yes Monty was vain
egotistical and a timed downright mean
but he was also a key figure in the
second world war and his battles and his
decisions will echo down through history
for centuries after all of us are gone